[Music]
perhaps time for a new generation people
you're entering little discourse for the
first time particular line their first
interaction with that gives you identity
politics
yep and that is a very polarizing thing
online is it evening in trance of the
left and right flesh left economic
discourse to also pair that with
identity politics and I see it again I
see the two mutually constitutive you
can't understand race without
understanding the economic basis of
colonialism you can't understand the
role of women in society I think as a
man without materialist feminist Marxism
right so I think that the two are are
deeply integrated I not give you an
example I was in Waterloo the other day
and I got the escalators and there's
just black a black guy first of course
you're not the Lion King then I go to
the toilet above every urinal is a
picture of a four year old emaciated
young girl black and people say we're
all the same no every single image I'm
being subjected to show me that black
people are very very different to how
we're yeah how we are in the West right
why is that it's because of how
capitalism developed over the last five
hundred years and so if somebody is a
person of color and they're angry how
the police relate to them behave to them
absolutely I'm not going to deny that
fact and it's a big you know from it's
just a civil you don't need to be a
socialist to address that you can be a
liberal and say no quality of the law
what I would say is there's a deeper
context as to why that is happening
there's a historical set of reasons as
to why that's happening and so I don't
think you can understand one without the
other
however I want to dismiss identity
politics and say you don't you don't get
the whole thing I would say that the
economic kind of analysis enriches your
understanding of identity actually
particularly in Britain because were a
post imperial power we need to be very
very clear about our role within
creating a world which is what we did
after the 1700s a world of capitalism
but also a world of whiteness and the
creation of whiteness is a social
category it's a socially constructed
category yes clearly people have white
skin so if you have different colored
skins
but that delineation of white people
from other people is a social construct
so I'll give an example if you meet a
Muslim convert told me Robinson came out
of prison the other day had a big beard
had hair we were joking you look I'm
Muslim convert he actually reminded me
of a Chechen that for for Isis in Iraq
and the point is how you racialized just
threw away you dress or your name or
your facial hair so my name might add my
mother's husband's now it wasn't my dad
Aaron pizzas I was clean-shaven I went
to a grammar school so I was racialized
it's kind of like European II Middle
East me maybe right but if my name was
tariq ramadhan and I grow a beard I'm
wearing it's a kir on my head I'm
racialized as a Muslim so we need to
understand racialization the
construction of race and Britain played
a really important role in that that
shift alongside campus and that
construction and race is it done as a
deliberate authorized agent of the
state's direction away from yeah well my
colleague unit of our media shock would
give you a far more erudite asks and I
could offer but if you look at for
instance the Confederacy you know the
southern states the United States yet
working-class whites in the Confederacy
however they consented to a system where
they were subordinate to other white
people because they were above
working-class or indentured slave blacks
and so clearly in society that
distinction between the poorest poor of
white communities and that being
reproduced by the interest because at
least it gives them succor to know well
they're not these people you see in this
country in the 19th century with the
Irish the poorest for of English working
class Paul hated the Irish and that
suits Italy interests extraordinarily
well helps undermine Chartres them hopes
undermine republicanism helps undermine
labor made socialism so couldn't agree
more although it's not that new you know
I think this is this integral to systems
of domination really since since the
18th century so how do we great done
that on the rise
stratification of society Wow I mean I
would I would start with the presumption
we're all racist and it's a perfectly
healthy place to start we're all racists
and then I think we have to constantly
interrogate our relations to
to trans people to people of color
nobody eliminates these things and this
is what I think Marxist this is
disagrees liberal right you can't just
step out of ideology right we're two
hundred thousand years old as a species
you know your ancestors God much think
I'm a hundred thousand years ago their
genome is imprinted on you the social
behaviors which we've accumulated at the
same time yes that's not imprinted in
your DNA it's imprinted very much in our
social processes Saudi you can just step
outside of ideology step outside of
history you can't and so I think one of
the real the valuable things of Marx in
the second half of 20th century is
understanding the oppression and
exploitation aren't the same thing
it took marks the teach us about
exploitation and the capitalism but it
took the scholars Frantz Fanon Michel
Foucault still refer to reach you it
took them to understand that oppression
is something a little bit different
sometimes almost always however this is
where I think Marx is very powerful they
overlap very very often oppressions
overlap Maitre matrices of exploitation
[Music]
within reason
I think it's more important to give them
resources you know you'll often go to an
event if you say oh let's ever let's
have a person of color speak woman of
color speak of trans let's think the
platform is no good if they haven't got
the resources if they haven't had the
training if you have a white kid 25
years have the best education money can
buy and then you go back you turn out
they're not starting at the same place
so it's not about well we'll give them a
quality in the labor market will give
the same platform for them to speak
their mind they haven't had access to
the same set of resources so you need to
give them a platform we also need to
build a society where resources like
housing education health care transport
information why call universal basic
services are available tool because I
believe in the liberal ends right I
believe that each person is uniquely
determined to define their own life but
that means nothing unless you have the
resources to do it
you're not self authoring your life if
you haven't got a roof over your head or
if you haven't got education or if
you're sick so the platforms matter but
so do the resource and how we build
society more generally so beyond just
darling
saying access to resources is an
obligation to pay reparations to certain
the global North in Britain I would see
constructing a socialist society where
housing education health care as a form
of reparations if it's freely available
to everyone regardless of race or class
I view that as a kind of reparations in
terms of north-south relationship
obviously a bit different I would say
the global North should pay for global
South the transition away from fossil
fuels I talk about that in the book you
do that through some of the mechanisms I
talked about with socializing finance
national investment banks and that was a
few things
it helped us meet our targets quickly
enough but it also as you've highlighted
helps us to begin to address the
historical inequalities built on racism
and camp ISM for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you